I don't think many Democrats disagree
that that we should figure out all the
facts behind this and it could be good
it could be bad whatever it is I think
it's important we know right I think at
this point Democrats are probably
excited for the prospect of getting rid
of Biden and getting something I heard
that one before yeah I mean you've heard
people saying that basically it's like
here's how you get rid of the guy
because because apparently he's playing
on running again he's already
campaigning and it's like he's in a weak
position if it ends up being DeSantis
against a bite and I don't think Biden
wins
I I I agree that he's probably too old
to run for a second term I I would I
would love for the Democrats to nominate
somebody that's younger
um I I think that if it was Trump Biden
I think Biden would win I think if it
was DeSantis Biden I think Biden's going
to have a difficult time who would you
guys vote for uh DeSantis or Biden it's
still Biden okay why though just because
I I agree more with his views